So then, I guess you know, this, there is a bug there definitely.
And then if next is equal to blank which is the character we want to
count the count is incremented using the plus, plus operator.
[COUGH] Then we read the next character again using the read.
function, the read method on on the stream.
And then it would print the character that we just read.
>> Should we really be printing all these characters on a new line every time?
Or do we want the sentence to actually look like the characters are one
after another in a sentence?
>> You have to say that was not specified.
So I made that decision but.
It didn't sound like a very good decision.
I mean, you think you're going to have this, [LAUGH] this line of characters,
vertical line of characters coming out that you, then it's difficult for
you to check if the sentence that I put in, that was the sentence,
try to figure out you know, if it actually caught them all and, and, and-
[CROSSTALK].
>> Kind of drives-
>> Right now it's a vertical line of integers, it's not even characters.
>> Yeah, that's true.
>> So, it's-
>> Even worse.
>> Right. >> Yeah, you're right, okay.
Okay, okay, that's fine.
I didn't realize that, that was going to be printed as an integer.
You're probably right.
And so it should be really printed as a character.
[CROSSTALK].
>> You didn't realize.
I mean, you never even ran your code once on your test.
>> I did run it I just, the input wasn't just that.
>> It's like students who appear in science class.
It just compile it doesn't work.
>> I mean, this is one of the advantages of-
[CROSSTALK].
[LAUGH].
>> This is actually, you know, one of the advantages of inspection.
I mean, this code, is could just, part of a larger piece of code and
so we're just reading it right now and didn't really.
[COUGH]. >> Go through a serious testing phase.
Yeah, I compiled. [COUGH].
>> To make sure there were no syntactic errors.
>> We can continue from here.
>> We can continue.
Thank you. [COUGH] Okay, so at this point-
>> We're going to get bite me to go see if he can compile it and
see if it even compiles.
I'm not even sure if it compiled yet.
>> Well, it may have of compiled.
I can't remember.
The last time I checked I know it didn't work.
It didn't give us what we wanted.
>> It does compile though.
I mean I'm positive about that.
>> Okay, okay.